hi how you doing you recover from that
New Year's hangover great happy 2024 in
the world where it's a new year but
probably more of the same I'm here
to give you my 10 anticipated movies of
2024 some things to keep in mind one if
there were movies that were on my
anticipated movies of 2023 list and the
movies were postponed and now they're
coming out in 2024 I'm not going to re
I'm not going to double up on it I
already said Dune last year sorry Dune
still looking forward to you seems
unfair for Dune part two to be on two of
these lists two years in a row also
quent Tarantino the movie critic was
supposed to come out in 2024 but filming
was delayed so I don't believe it's
coming out in 2024 if he double times it
and it's somehow still makes a 2024
release date we'll count that among the
anticipated also there a lot of there's
a lot of setup for this video I
apologize for that you might see movies
that aren't on this list well the
reasons are simple of which I have a few
one I like to keep it to 10 maybe the
movies that aren't on the list are 11 12
13 Etc two maybe the force sounding
sequel just sounds unnecessary to me so
I'm not that interested right now three
I've seen the trailer the trailer either
didn't do anything for me or just looked
like complete and total ass or four and
probably most likely in me constructing
this list searching the movies coming
out this year I just passed me by it's
simple it's stupid but it happens also
these aren't going to be 10-minute
dissertations as to why I'm looking
forward to these movies I might have
more to say about some than others but
in the end this is just a brief hey
these are 10 movies in 2024 I'm looking
forward to myself all right no need for
the dramatic countdown of 10 9 8
anything like that these aren't in any
particular order so first up Argyle
Matthew vaugh can be hit or miss but
when he's a hit he's an absolute hit
Argyle looks like the fun excentric spy
Thriller genre he's now known for
because a Kingsman all about a writer
who apparently accidentally wrote the
truth so now she gets wrapped up in the
Spy World all with Henry Cavell getting
a lot of for his haircut in the
movie I was like what you guys aren't
Broken Arrow fans that's totally the
Travolta from Broken Arrow next up
Mickey 17 I do not know jack about
the premise of this movie from the very
brief under a minute I believe teaser
trailer I simply know what I need to
know and that is bong Jun ho is
directing Robert patson starring for me
that's enough next the fall gu starring
Ryan Gosling Emily Blunt directed by
David Leech co-director of the first
John Wick also Deadpool 2 a stunt man
who retires gets brought back into the
business the star of this big movie
production disappears The Trailer looks
like it could be a fun exciting popcorn
time at the movies cherry on top I like
that it's showing love to the unsung
heroes of action movies The Stunt crew
we go from co-director of John Wick to a
movie that's a spin-off of John Wick
ballerina one of the things that stands
out in the John Wick movies the John
Wick universe is the world they built
there this world of Fantastical
locations rules assassin code you give
me that world in a Revenge Quest
starring Ana day armis and I'm going to
look forward to that next we have
Deadpool 3 supposed this had to be on
here the first two Deadpools were a
great time at the movies the Deadpool 3
has taken a while to actually
come out Studio buys strikes there are
reasons for it Ryan Reynolds is so good
in the role I can't help but look
forward to that any given year this
looks to be Deadpool on a Multiverse
Adventure filled with references and
cameos which thematically looks to be a
great opportunity for Deadpool to
address or talk a proper amount of
on Studio over Alliance on Multiverse
and Cameo porn the Deadpool movies are
fun they surprise in a world where Hugh
Jackman said he was done playing
Wolverine but he's back in in Deadpool 3
Dawning his classic yellow outfit they
definitely seem to want to give fans
what they want next up Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes why because that
reboot Trilogy of Planet of the Apes I
thought was great and I'm curious to see
that world some generations after the
fact this is directed by West ball the
director of those Maze Runner movies
which the first one I remember
shockingly enjoying it enjoying most of
it anyway the other two weren't as good
as the first one I go in cautious to
Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes still
it's the pre- existing Trilogy that this
is springboarding off of that is selling
me on that the movie does have my
curiosity next up a quiet place day one
though this is not directed by John
krinski it's kind of like Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes where it's the movies
that came before it that is pitching me
and selling me on this new movie though
we got a glimpse of when the aliens
first arrived in the previous movie I've
always been curious to see a more
in-depth look at that that's why I mean
you take a look at The Walking Dead you
Remember The Walking Dead they're still
making Walking Dead old generation
has no idea the event that The Walking
Dead was when it was airing at one point
but the point is a fear of The Walking
Dead was a look at well how it actually
all fell apart because the Walking Dead
just kind of picks up with Rick Grimes
waking up in the hospital and never got
to see it and that's what made Fear The
Walking Dead feel different and feel
unique from The Walking Dead until it
became The Walking Dead also we all
enjoy navigating a fictional apocalypse
but there is something else to be said
about seeing how it became that the
Genesis of that next up Robert edar is
directing a remake of NOS Fatu I would
say that's a match made in heaven I feel
like we're talking about another place
point is that is a perfect marriage
those of you who don't know that's a
remake of the classic silent German film
NOS Fatu made in 1922 they believe
they've done a remake sense remaker 2
definitely one I heard about him wanting
to do this back when the witch came out
I think then I stopped hearing about it
I was like okay I guess it's not
happening so I was pleased to find out
no that is not dead that's still
happening and he's still directing it I
can't find an official picture of Bill
Skarsgard as orlock but Robert egar says
he looks great I mean it' be his job to
say so but I actually believe him
William defo is in this Robert Edgar's
remake of NOS Fatu he was also in Shadow
of the
vampire so what's reality next up if
you're looking for that escapism from
the social political divide well there's
a civil war movie coming out not of the
Captain America variety but of the oh
yeah one day variety The Curiosity from
this one comes from whether or not it is
going going to be kept a political is it
going to be like a political Roar Shack
are you going to see tactics used by the
right and the left that led to this are
half the people going to walk out of
this movie and be like and that's why
you shouldn't vote for Donald Trump and
the other half walk out of the movie and
be like and that's why you shouldn't
vote for Joe Biden I don't know that
would be an interesting way to go about
this but this is a movie about a modern
American Civil War social political
divide that is coming out in election
year right so you can bet this is
absolutely positively not going to be a
Hol would movie telling you how to vote
this November right no it probably will
be they probably won't use the term
Republican or Democrat but there will be
signs and tells in the way people talk
in which people will be like okay so
that's that side but when watching the
trailer I got to say it was when Jesse
plans came on I was like oh oh here
we go he's so good how is he that good
it's he's perfect for a movie like
this okay what kind of American are
you
it's just it just hits because it's so
real it's real because those are
conversations people already have might
not be phrased that way but those
conversations do happen that's why
there's a part of me that's like is is
it strictly speaking responsible to make
this movie right now navigating a
fictional apocalypse that's fun I said
not one that's this real I'm not
necessarily looking forward to this
movie or the conversations surrounding
this movie but if I have had curiosity
bottled up into one movie this year it's
the it's this next up Joker fully ad do
F fly ad I'll try to get the
pronunciation down by the time the movie
comes out point is Joker 2 now I thought
the first Joker was great when it became
the highest grossing rated R film of all
time I was like okay so blank checks are
going out and there's going to be a
joker two looks like Lady Gaga is
playing Harley Quinn and fly Ado means
the transference of one's delusional
mindset onto
another Harley Quinn the reports that
the movie is going to be a musical is
strange though Lady Gaga is an
incredible singer and actor so she's a
great pick for this it could work it
could be the detriment of the film we
will see now Todd Phillips track record
for sequels notwithstanding C Hangover 2
and three Can't Help It movie has my
curiosity and attention and that makes
10 those are 10 movies I'm looking
forward to in 2024 with any luck one or
two of them might end up on my top 10
best list of 2024 video at the end of
the year this year as many of the years
before most of the gems are probably
going to be movies I don't even know
about yet but we will see what happens
as Kane said at the end of Legacy of
Kane's Soul Reaver fate promises more
twists before this drama unfolds
completely but the movies you're looking
forward to in 2024 whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
more
[Music]